i always wonder when my flight gets
canceled if that's god looking out for
me or not yeah i think my flight
yesterday was an old plane it had the
the tvs that stick out of the seat like
the brick ones it almost looked like a
thermostat a little bit it's like a tan
box yeah it was delta but it was the
pilot was pissed i had my foot on the
wall and he goes that's not a very uh he
goes this is not a very mature thing to
do take your foot off wow he he said
like it was his plane which look i
understand he's flying that [ __ ] by all
means but he said it like he like pulled
it out of the garage like it was
collector delta 747 well it's also
that's a very subtle way of saying
you're in first class also i do want to
say that
you know you know when you're flying
first class from la to nashville it's a
that's a 300 upgrade but i was feeling
myself first weekend back of uh you know
i was feeling myself a little bit
there's only one place on the plane you
could put your foot on a wall or the
very back
the stewardess you just got it up on the
coffee maker
yeah i mean the stewardesses are getting
fight they're all on their phone out
there listening to loud ipads and [ __ ]
watching coco melon and [ __ ] yeah it's
great it's definitely a different vibe
out there now in the skies yeah but you
know i uh i feel like they nobody wanted
to be there the pilot was like pissed he
was there because somebody used you know
pilots used the same front bathroom as
everybody else oh yeah they'd have one
in the cockpit it's so weird that oh my
ex-girlfriend's dad was a pilot and they
used to urinate into a jug up there i
think like a folgers can would make
sense
well
that's probably old school but like
they're real old some guy brings a metal
candy urinated yeah but the folgers now
are plastic so i feel like that's
bananas yeah it's not good for the
environment if a plane goes down that
see i just wonder is god looking out for
me is like like could this plane go down
right uh no i feel that
how do you ever think that that could
happen do you ever feel like
because when i was younger it happened a
lot getting canceled uh getting canceled
by god dying in a plane crash i do i had
that fear yesterday because the pilot
was i've never seen a pilot piss and he
was an older gentleman i've never seen
somebody like mad mad and it's like
we're about to take off you know
somebody
rub him off a little bit or give him
some cbd gummies because he was on one
and i was like this is the guy in charge
of the plane
you know that's the guy everybody else
is [ __ ] like think about how you
drive right think about how you drive
when you're having a tough day you're
you're [ __ ] you see red lights as a
suggestion you're like maybe so i'm like
on takeoff i had this weird euphoric
feeling was like what if he just did a
nosedive
what if what if today's a day is like
you know that is once dude think about a
pilot
you really are you're that you you
really have the ability to say who who
how many do you want god yeah you know
in your hand how many you want god and
also ten dozen yeah i got ten dollars
this [ __ ] got his feet on the board
so let's take him out delta should be
who is the pilot's wife how is she doing
that's what i'm saying taking care of
them they got to be treating these
people
i salute uh pilots when i get off i go
thank you for the flight because because
everybody nobody makes eye contact with
returning they say thank you to the
flight attendants which i get that but
like the pilots are the you know like
salute i'll lean in there and yes i'll
say kiss him on the cheek good job
fellas yeah or ma'am yeah right and i'll
say that even at the same fellows or
ma'am and they know they don't yeah and
even the lady if she's a female pilot
she wants to be called fella
she got a little more gray hair than
usual you're like i see what you're
doing with that toupee i see what you're
doing yeah some women just want to go so
hard that you they want you to call them
man right fella but that's i feel like
pilots don't get enough uh credit also
if i was a pilot i would be like i would
go on the intercom be like i sure would
love some starbursts right now
and then i'd wait for somebody to be
like come bring it up and then if nobody
does i'd be like y'all want turbulence a
little [ __ ] rattle rattle
what do you think
like dude one this guy dan gilbert you
said the best joke and he still has it
because it's his joke he said turbulence
is a as a button that rich that people
in first class press
i wish i had that yesterday i want to
[ __ ] with everybody back there row 23
y'all awake yet
they should have
or if you're playing those games where
everybody on the plane can play and you
win you should be able to get a little
remix them a little oh yeah just see
what's going on stir them up a little
bit yeah i uh i always think that like
if my phone's not on airplane mode like
it's it's gonna [ __ ] some up i but but
then i've been on flights where i forget
to turn it off and it's the same flight
so that's something i want to know is
airplane mode a hoax
you know a lot of things that vote i
think they used to have like
probably
you know back in the day they probably
what was before that
before airplane mode yeah who's turned
it off
or right then they had air they'd like
silent mode because airplane mode's such
a specific thing i don't even know what
it does it just blocks calls i guess
it's supposed to stop the signal but
nothing can stop the signal see my phone
i saw my phone the other night get up
and get something to drink
like this thing's been offered my phone
just get a mountain dew code red right
now
sometimes i think when the flight gets
canceled that that's like i just want
you know and maybe it's egotistical to
think that it's like oh is that no is
that your part of god saving my life
because i would rather that than like
you know when you get you like board the
plane like oh we gotta work on the
engine for like two to three hours like
that doesn't make me feel better like
just lie to me be like the pilot had to
go get some egg bites from starbucks
right like like when they're like oh
we're working on the engine we'll be
good in a sec like i don't want to know
that
yeah but i
it used to be dicer you would hear the
dude in their work and you'd see a guy
with an oil canner it said oil on it oh
yeah yeah he was a cartoon figure
what is going on
i don't want to know anything about like
like i literally i i edit a lot of my
videos on flights because i don't want
to think about the fact that i'm like
just in the air like when my phone dies
and like it's just like the tv on the
plane like not working and all i have is
my thoughts that's the worst flight of
my life i'm just sitting there thinking
really i'm just i have a lot of anxiety
in that sense of like
you know your childhood was that we
didn't have because they didn't have
phones yeah i mean i don't the [ __ ] i
did growing up probably like sudoku
puzzles or some dumb [ __ ] or like made
it tic-tac-toe but i like i like i need
to do something so i don't think about
the fact that i'm just like in the sky
right it's yeah yeah i guess it's
interesting i guess part of the thing of
a flight is to try to trick people you
think they try to trick you more to
thinking that you're in the sky like on
the inside of the windows draw have like
a forest or something yeah or like a
glass like bottom floor just like but
put it like one aisle just one aisle and
you get to pay extra for it like row 13
you just get to see below you
that's kind of hard
bro
in the [ __ ] flights with the feet
one time we were landing somewhere and
it was a prop plane right so what does
that mean it was just a small plane
oh the connecting flight ones were scary
yeah it was a real small one so
you see the propeller something
because there's only a couple things it
could be you're in the air you know bird
bird
alien kevin yeah a smaller plane
person you know loose person skydiver
yeah so i'm like what so everybody's
like what the [ __ ]
you know some guy's like i know what it
is
yeah that's actually just the tropical
storm with the stratosphere what do you
even say wife's like shut up everybody
there's four jack daniels bottles
spilling out from his waist so did you
ever find out what it was we got out bro
and no joke in the front
um in one of the um
rotors right
there was a
bird
things mangled
like a um
wings
enough of a wing enough of one where you
knew what happened oh no it was like a
mallard no no it was bigger than that i
would think it was probably pelican or
damn i mean yeah because usually to
on the plane but i will say some of
those connecting flights where you got
to like you land in like seattle but you
got to go to spokane and it's one of
these like mountainy flights yeah and
you can still see the propeller on the
it's like an uncovered propeller you
ever take in one of those
oh yeah that's what i'm talking about so
this was one where something got you
know and part of me wonders because i
felt us go off course a little part of
me wonders if one of the old dogs up
there was like you know what see how
theo's doing i'm about to well no i'm
gonna hit something oh oh oh he's like
i'm done
because how hard would it be if you're
having a bad day you're tired and you're
just a mallard your wife's doing
something you know it's something with
your husband cause there's a lot of gay
pilots now too
which
i'm fine with it but it's just like do
we know enough about their relationships
to know if the guy can if something goes
bad
like i feel like we know enough where
like if a straight man in a straight
relationship if something gets real bad
the guy
there's been enough study where he's
maybe not to crash is a gay dude or gay
woman just going to be like you know
like
i would love to see a pilot with a mood
ring on it you know but like when they
don't know about when they don't know
about but if i walk on and it's like
blue or green i'm like okay they're
feeling all right but it's like bright
red or yellow yeah we might need a uh we
might need to delay this a few hours go
get some some chamomile or something
there should be intel on the pi so you
can look even on the app it's like hey
you know
uh
like you know samuel rhonda
even on uber it says like their favorite
activities the parks favorite sports
team i want to know more about the pilot
yeah also i think like you know i'm sure
they have a lounge for pilots but like
they should have like the delta sky club
should be four pilots right like this
place where they can just post up crush
a couple of michelobs
i don't know but i uh i don't know if
you can drink i know globe
okay one yeah or a non-alcoholic one
just to feel like they're doing
something yes
just to give them that like that edge
mentally
actually never mind that's a terrible
idea i don't know man now you got me
wanting it yeah you just won cause i bet
if i'm a pi there's no way some of them
aren't drinking man one of my
ex-girlfriends that my childhood
girlfriend dad was a pilot or he and he
had a couple extra families and
everything dude he had like it was crazy
bro it was really just you know being
the best pilot you could be oh yeah if
i'm gonna be landing if i'm sleeping
here after year yeah he's pumping yeah
i'm i'm having some kids yeah well i've
met people at my shows yeah like on like
a friday night they're all like a little
hamburger yeah man we're all pilots at
the local airport and they're all like
hammered hammered and i'm like they're
not getting hammered in the morning but
like a little hungover a little on edge
yeah because here's the thing you can't
assume that pilots have a magical power
maybe they do maybe part of going
through the air force and going through
flight school they're like they start to
weed out the people who have really bad
hangovers i bet they do yeah can you be
hungover and in the military
yeah dude that's the military okay
it's just called you
but i just feel like they just plow
right through mentally you know they
just go hoorah and they [ __ ] beat the
[ __ ] out of that hangover
yeah i mean still
they got it though they they have the
hangover to beat the [ __ ] but they just
cruise right past it yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices some guy just brings you one
option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one
you